immigration crisis in Europe three  children drown Syrian refugees it's  become a symbol of the disparate surge  of refugees bung the dead  several children including a baby girl  one issue that needs to be addressed is  the overly broad prohibition in our  immigration law that excludes any  refugee who has provided any kind of  support to an army rebel group even a  group that we in the United States  support this would be ace a federally  sanctioned the Welcome Party if you will  to potential terrorists in the United  States could we take more I mean Germany  is taking 800,000 I'm not talking about  taking on a permanent basis it warrants  mentioning the United States has  provided more than four billion dollars  in humanitarian assistance at this point  I don't have any announcements along  you